والغرب يزيد من مساعداته
العسكرية وميدان الحروب
الاجتماعي اثر نشره لما زعم انه
عقد امتياز حصلت عليه شركة
ان يشكل تحديا للنظام الدفاعي
الامريكي كما يرى بعض المحللين.
فلتنظر الى هذه الطفلة السورية
هنا تتحدث.
للصواريخ الباليستية العابرة
للقارات اي سي بي ام بعدد يمكن
برفقة طفلته التي يرجح ان تكون
خليفة يستعرضان اكبر عرض
البناء قبل اخراج العالقين. ورغم
الزلزال وضحاياه وكل تلك المآسي
هذه السيدة التركية انقاذها مع
ابنتها بعد اثنتين وتسعين ساعة
الاكياس كي ياخذ جثث اسرته.
فيالى قساوة دقائق الانتظار ان
الف مصاب والاعداد لا تتوقف حتى
اشعار اخر. بينما يقدر عدد
الامريكية رفع العقوبات عن سوريا
لمدة ستة اشهر على خلفية
الجزائر غاضبة من فرنسا. لتسحب
سفيرها من باريس بعد هروب
اثار صحفي اسرائيلي عاصفة من
ردود الفعل على مواقع التواصل
السوري فيالى حظكم التعيس ايها
السوريون. الاحداث والتطورات.
الامريكان والتنين الصيني. وبعد
ايام من ازمة المنطاد الصيني
والاعلام المصري ينفي. العمليات
الروسية تتكثف في اوكرانيا.
الفرنسية مواصلة جهودها لتعزيز
مع الجزائر. زعيم كوريا الشمالية
مسؤولة اطلاقا وتنتهك القواعد
الاساسية للاداب الدبلوماسية.
والتوترات على اشدها. وما عاد في
الوقت متسع لتبدأ المواجهة بين
اسرائيلية لادارة قناة السويس
المصرية لمدة تسعة وتسعين عاما
الناشطة المدانة باحكام قضائية
اميرة براوي بينما اكدت الخارجية
تزداد الكوارث. والولايات
المتحدة تدعو النظام السوري
الزلزال. الزلزال لا تنتهي
والقلب يقطر دما عند رؤيتها.
سادة. ليعلنها وزير البيئة
التركي. سنعمل على توفير جميع
بكين. فهل اقتربت المواجهة?
رائحة الموت في كل مكان. لا صوت
يعلو على صوت الزلزال وضحاياه في
تركيا وسوريا. وبعد اكثر من خمسة
يا له من موقف قاس ومحزن. وهنا
يتم انتشالها من تحت الانقاض بعد
ست وثمانين ساعة وهي على قيد
الحياة. بينما يحبس هذا المشهد
بوتين خسر اوكرانيا جاء الرد
فورا من المتحدث باسم الكريملين
الروسية. اوكرانيا. الصين تتألم
وامريكا تتكلم. الاجواء مكهربة
ديمتري بسكوف قائلا انه لا يوجد
ادنى شك بنجاح العملية العسكرية
لكن يبدو ان واشنطن تتجاهل
تحذيرات الصين ذاتها. وبعد كل
للسماح بمرور المساعدات عبر كل
المعابر بين اعلنت وزارة الخزانة
القتالية. لكن الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون يحبط امال
الذي اسقطته امريكا فوق اراضيها.
صرح بايدن قايلان ان الرئيس
هذه التوترات هنا الولايات
المتحدة وبريطانيا واستراليا
قلوبهم للتحفيز ليضحك ويلعب
معهم. انها براءة الاطفال يا
الاحتياجات المطلوبة لاعادة
الاعمار. يا للعجب! نتكلم عن
العالقة دفء صدره لتشعر بالامان.
وهنا هذا السوري ينتظر حاملا
ها هو الجيش التركي يجدد
استهدافه لمواقع في الشمال
اللحظة وصلت الارقام الى اكثر من
اثنين وعشرين الف قتيل وتسعين
المتضررين من الزلزال باكثر من
ستة وعشرين مليون شخص. في سوريا
ايام تتضاءل امال العثور مزيد من
الناجين تحت الانقاض. فحتى هذه
من الزلزال. وهذا الطفل خرج
ليكافئ المنقذين بابتسامة شحنت
الانفاس. منقذ جزائري لم ينم طول
الليل حتى لامست هذه الطفلة
الصيني يواجه مشاكل هائلة خصوصا
على المستوى الاقتصادي بايدن
يجرون مناورة جوية لمحاكاة كيف
ستبدو المواجهة العسكرية مع
ومن المساعدات العسكرية الى
الورطة اللوجستية. حيث اقر
الدول التي تتجاهل تحذيرات
وتقترب من مواجهة الدب الروسي
والولايات المتحدة تواجه ازمة
غير مسبوقة ولا بوادر لاي تحسن
قدمتها الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية تعتمد على بيانات
معادية لها بحسب تعبيره ليرد
رئيس مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي شارل
ليقول زلنسكي ان الجيش الاوكراني
يدافع عن اوروبا امام اعتى قوة
بينغ لا اجد احدا. لتشعل هذه
التصريحات ازمة جديدة بين واشنطن
المسؤولون الاوكرانيون بان معظم
ضرباتهم بانظمة الصواريخ التي
جدولي زعيما عالميا واحدا على
استعداد لتبادل منصبه مع شي جين
ليفجرها الرئيس الاوكراني بقوله
ان عددا من قادة دول الاتحاد
للملاجئ. ليتجه زلنسكي الى
بروكسل والهدف قمة الاتحاد
بوست. ليعلن نائب وزير الخارجية
الروسي ان العلاقات بين
بالمانيا تشبه الامواج في حركتها
صعودا وهبوطا وفق صحيفة شبيجل.
شولدز قائلا انه مضطر باستمرار
باقناعه. مضيفا ان علاقته
هجماتها. وهنا هجمات صاروخية
روسية جديدة تستهدف كل المدن
الاوروبي. ليدعو الى تسريع تقديم
الدعم لاوكرانيا لمواجهة روسيا.
ميشيل ان الاسابيع المقبلة سوف
تكون حاسمة في اوكرانيا. الذي
وبكين. لتعلن بكين غضبها من
بايدن معتبرة ان تصريحاته غير
زالنسكي بتأكيده ان الطائرات
المقاتلة التي تطالب بها كييف لا
وبعد ان قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
فتيلها. انتهى عهد الهدوء وحان
وقت الاجتياح. وروسيا تكثف
ترفع سياط العقوبات مؤقتا على
دمشق بينما تعلن الجزائر غضبها
المواقع التي قدمتها واشنطن او
حلفاؤها وذلك وفق صحيفة واشنطن
هناك اسلحة بديلة واكثر فائدة
ويتم تسليمها بشكل اسرع. كما هي
وهذا لا يترك مجالا للدبلوماسية
بحسب قوله. ردود الروس تتواصل.
المرة من المانيا. لكن الغريب
انه هاجم المستشار الالماني اولف
يقصده ميشيل يا ترى. لم يتوقف عن
طلب الدعم ليطلب المساعدات هذه
الاوروبي اعدادهم خلال القمة
لتزويد اوكرانيا بالطائرات
يمكن تحت اي ظرف تسليمها في
الاسابيع المقبلة. مبررا ذلك بان
مختلف ارجاء البلاد. والسلطات
السكان على الاحتماء والاتجاه
الاوكرانية وصافرة الانذار تدوي
للتحذير من الغارات الجوية في
كيم جونغ يرعب امريكا بوجبة دسمة
من الصواريخ. وما بين تركيا
بشرائه قناة السويس. فهل هذه
حقيقة? معركة طحن العظام يشتعل
من الظروف. بايدن يضع الملح في
الجرح الصيني وبكين ترد بقوة.
وسوريا. عداد الضحايا لا يتوقف
وامل نجاة البقية يتضائل. واشنطن
روسيا. فهل حان وقت المواجهة?
والزلانسكي يهاجم المانيا ويطلب
والناس يهرعون للملاجئ. كييف
تفضح امريكا بتدخلها في الحرب ضد
منها المساعدات في الوقت ذاته.
ايعقل هذا? دول اوروبية تتحدى
الاوكرانية هو من سيقول كلمته
فلمن ستكون الغلبة?
من فرنسا وباريس تتودد معتذرا.
والكيان الاسرائيلي عقودا تفيد
الروس وتمد الاوكران بالطائرات.
وماكون يرد لا يمكن تحت اي ظرف